foreign
Parker I live in Los Angeles but I'm
from Canada
if you guys want evidence that I'm
Canadian this is a true story I once had
someone ride over my foot with their
bicycle and I said sorry
and then I said thank you
it's a true story
and then we both did shots of maple
syrup really
and then we made out in the snow
it's quite it was lovely I apologize for
everything man I do I apologize the
first time a girl told me she loved me I
was just like
sorry
here's what's really funny there's a
Canadian city called Surrey s-u-r-r-e-y
it's right next to us Suri is filled
with Indian and South Asian people so it
has a bunch of Indian South Asian shops
stores boutiques the whole bit which
means at least once in history the
following scene has played out hey
where'd you get your sorry sorry
[Applause]
if you don't like that joke
sorry
and also thank you
so I'm from Canada but I live in Los
Angeles I think the biggest difference
between Canada and La is the extent to
which people in La fetishize wealth like
it's to the point where I'm shocked that
there isn't a wealth category for adult
videos
but then I thought about it and I
realized that those well-fetished videos
do exist it's just they're not where you
think they'd be they're not on adult
websites no they're on
architecturaldigest.com
people just touring their massive
Estates while we sit at home watching on
our laptops in the dark going show me
show me a closet that's way too big
show me a closet so big you could house
refugees in it
but don't because then where would you
keep your cufflinks
I'm terrified man I'm terrified that
LA's changing me that I'm becoming one
of those people who chases money who
fetishizes wealth who wants to be a
billionaire when I say that people get
angry they get defensive it's like well
what's wrong with being rich what's
wrong with being a billionaire what's
wrong with being financially Savvy it's
just like yo man if you own a billion of
anything that doesn't make you Savvy
that makes you a hoarder
hey
thank you
like there's no episode of orders where
they go into someone's house and see a
billion pieces of unopened mail that are
just like man this guy's savvy
what a shrewd collector of unopened male
he is I hope he writes a book
people get angry man they get defensive
they're just like oh there's valid
reasons to be rich there's valid reasons
to be rich I just want to be rich to
build generational wealth that's it I
just want to build generational wealth
and it's just like yo man why would you
do that to your kids like no one's
favorite kid at school was Bentley
Worthington III
like no one has fond memories of Cadbury
money nuts Jr
of the famous money nuts Clan
who made their fortune in shipping
no one needs it man no one needs it
people get angry they're like oh this is
there's personal reasons to want to be
rich like the only reason why I want to
be rich is to cement my legacy that's it
I just want to cement my legacy and
she's like yo man being rich isn't Gonna
Make History remember you you know how I
know there's 2
668 billionaires on the planet right now
name them
you can't and that's why they're still
alive
I mean hell there's 12 billionaires in
this room right now and we don't know
who they are they're sitting next to us
picking their nose and we're just like
man I hope things work out for this guy
[Applause]
being rich being a billionaire that's
not going to make people remember you
man for some reason we all have this
fantasy at some point in the future
we're all going to be huddled around a
campfire and someone's gonna go
you know whose life I really admired
that of
oh sure the world is ending and
Humanity's doomed well you know who
lived their life the right way
Taiwanese petrochemical Zion Liao long
shin
oh who me oh I'm just a farmer works the
soil loves his family I'll be forgotten
you know who history will never forget
Italian air conditioning Mogul just to
be DeLonghi
being a billionaire man isn't going to
make history remember you it's not going
to leave you a legacy you want to leave
a legacy there's only one thing you need
to do you want to leave a legacy you
just need to be the one house on the
street that gives out full-size
chocolate bars for Halloween
that's it
that's it Legacy cemented it's been 30
years since I went trick-or-treating and
me and my brother still talk about 39
Brennan Drive
we're just like oh Sam and Lucy oh those
people were Saints they were Angels
someone should build a statue in their
honor to celebrate their legacy as they
enriched people in the audience who were
offended by those jokes I only have one
word for you
sorry
and also thank you now let's go make out
in the snow my name's partis Parker
thank you for coming to my second TED
Talk